[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining me today I know it's been at
least I've had a really hard time
choosing between talks I actually had
circled solving puzzles with our before
I realize I probably should show up for
my own talk to give it so thank you all
so much for coming my name is Emily
Robinson and I'll be talking about
building an a/b testing analytics system
with our and SHINee all my slides are
available on the link up here bitly
slash our studio 19 and you can also if
you're a tweeter you can follow me on
Twitter at Robinson underscore yes I
usually live tweet a lot of talks
although I will not be live tweeting my
own
sadly all right so a little bit about me
so first this is very important this is
my part-time dog Abby I call her my
part-time dog because I steal her for my
parents occasionally I've been I'm a
data scientist at data camp where I work
on the growth team on experiments and
that's a lot of what you'll be hearing
about today
ivenn an are user for about seven years
I first learned are when I went to Rice
University for undergraduate and I
walked into class one day and I had this
viewed a really good teacher or like
statistics professor and I texted my
brother this who is who is studying
computational biology like I have this
great professor his name is Hadley
Wickham and my brother is David Robinson
he'll be giving the keynote and he went
you're being taught by Hadley Wickham
who back then was was not as well-known
as he is now so I was really lucky to
get a learn our first from him and some
things I enjoy talking about include
building and finding data science
community one of the reasons I'm so
excited to be at our studio conference
this is my third time here is that the
art community is just so friendly I'm
sure many of you already knows know this
you saw Hadley started off his talk
today asking people to you know please
be extra welcoming follow the pac-man
rule so I just really love it diversity
and stem I'm part of the are ladies
group if you're at the opening reception
you might have seen their poster their
group for promoting gender diversity and
are they're all around the world with
different chapters i really suggest
checking them out and finally of course
our so just so this talk will make a
little more sense if you're not familiar
with data camp it's an online data
science learning platform so it's a
little over 200 courses now in our
Python shell sequel
kind of all the big languages this is
one of our art courses and it's a you
know way to learn interact interactively
in the browser so you have short video
lessons and then you code what is av
testing so let's say we have a user
Linda and Linda logs on to data camp one
day and she's interested in learning
deep learning so Linda could maybe see
this page and that's one of our course
pages there's about a 50% chance of this
if we're running an a/b test on it but
she also could have seen this page so
you might notice there a couple
differences here right the color but a
big one is that registration form that's
not on the page
so what AV testing is is randomly
assigning visitors to your website to
one of two or more experiences sometimes
it involves changes on the page here
sometimes it's things like changes to a
search algorithm or making the page
faster but the idea is that by randomly
assigning people and you know running
these conditions at the same time you're
controlling for all the other factors so
this lets you know that if you see a
difference between the control and the
treatment group and you run everything
properly any behavioral difference
should be because of your change then
you can be really confident it's had the
impact you hoped it would life before
data camp I was a data analyst at Etsy
and that's where I got started on
experimentation so I worked on over 60
experiments with our search team Etsy
had been doing experimentations for over
eight years at that point and running
over 500 experiments per year to support
all of this Etsy had a big team of data
engineers so there are over five of them
working full-time on the data
experimentation platform which IT had
custom built over a thousand metrics
were computed for each experiment there
was a really nice UI that visualized all
of this data so we could see things like
confidence intervals you know power
calculations for detecting 1% change you
can even customize that so this was
really really great and I come to data
camp in April and I know that part of my
job is going to be helping start
experimentation at data camp but I still
felt a little bit like this in that
first couple weeks now to be very clear
especially from what data camp who might
be watching I did not lie on my resume
but here it was very different there was
no system for planning analyzing or
presenting experiment results I think
they'd only run about one or two tests
before I joined and there were no data
engineers to build it and again that's
partly why I was running as a data
scientist but this part would be a bit
new and I want to share four lessons I
learned along the way the first is build
tools to save yourself time who here has
ever had a first this than that question
something like who tried ax then did why
what percent of people who did X then
did Y what was the last thing people did
before doing Y or what were all the
things people did after doing X right so
they can be you know structured
differently maybe you're interested in
all the behavior afterwards just the
first time but really it's you have two
sets of behaviors and you want to know
follow one user and understand what
happened first this than that
and this is the type of questions I
would ask an a/b testing say what
percentage of the people that treatment
first control registered and this would
be registered after starting the
experiment so I'd have experiment starts
and registrations what were the ad click
said at a course start within two days
and my first attempt at doing this
evolved a lot of lengthy repetitive code
there's a ton of copying and pasting and
it was very hard to switch between
different types of funnels by which I
mean switching between something like I
want the first time they did this and
then the first time they do that I want
the first time they did this and
everything they did after that it wasn't
very easy to go between those types of
funnels and when you're doing repetitive
tasks you know it's a lot of you may
know here it's time to write a function
and in my case a package
unfortunately I faced a bit of an issue
which was this was me and writing
packages I sort of knew this was
something I even had written a blog post
a couple years ago that was like you
know writing my first art package part
one where I talk about how I'm gonna
write this our package and there was
never a part two they're actually still
is not so you know that it I was a
little I you know wasn't sure to do but
fortunately I had David Robinson at data
can wait
sorry not not that Dave Robinson that's
this one you might see him walking
around right it's got the big little
peak
so dave robinson is our chief data
scientist at data camp as i said also my
brother and he is very experienced in
writing packages so you know one day you
set up a hackathon for him me and one of
the other growth team members at data
camp to write the package funnel join
and if you'd like to try it out yourself
it's available on github and what funnel
join is is its goal is to make it easy
to analyze behavior funnels so I'm gonna
walk through how funnel join works the
structure of it is you start with two
tables the first table is your first set
of behaviors and then the second table
is your second set the one that you want
to happen afterward you tell it what the
user column names are because you want
to be able to connect the user across
tables you tell it what the time columns
are again you want to make sure the time
in the table on the left hand side
always has to be less than a time on the
right hand side has to happen before the
type of after join which I'm going to
talk about a little bit more and finally
the type of join so like inner
left-right all at all the deep layer
joins so one example is a first any
question what are all the courses people
started after visiting the homepage for
the first time so here I would write my
funnel join I write an after inner join
so using the type inner I specify in the
type argument the first - any and then I
have my time columns my user columns and
so I got off this table and you'll see
just a weird hope course started ah is
always greater than viewed at so now I
could say oh person three viewed the
home page you know on June 6 and we have
two entries for them even for the same
homepage view because I started two
different courses that's because I did a
first thing you join but if I wanted to
switch it up and say what percent of
people started the price all the pricing
page for the first time and then
subscribed I just changed the type of
funnel so a very similar structure
change type to first first after and now
because it's a left join right we also
have the n/a at the SUBSCRIBE dot what
if I want to say well that's great but
you know I really want a tight funnel I
want it to happen within four days I can
add a max cut argument so I give it a
diff time argument and now if I ran the
same code we see we bit more na s on the
subscribe da because even though those
people subscribed
didn't do it within four days you know
as I said there are many funnel types
supported so this last before first
after any any first any supports all
types of deep fire joins it works on
remote tables because uses deep fire so
it takes advantage of DB plier and bug
fixes pull request feature request
welcome please try it yourself and let
me know how it goes
so my second lesson is that everything
that can go wrong will go wrong a non
exhaustive list of things that have
happened people are put in both control
and treatment that should not happen you
should get one experience people in the
experiment have no pageviews they are
mysterious users with only back-end
events people have multiple experiment
starts in the same group there aren't
the same number of people in the control
versus treatment experiment starts
didn't have cookies so we couldn't even
track the user we couldn't link that
start to any other event we realized
here we really needed to check our
assumptions so we wrote up the stock of
things we needed to do because again
these are all things we didn't initially
think to check like they should if the
systems working correctly they should
happen and we started getting read
results we dug into it and we realized
oh all these things are going wrong my
initial solution was again this kind of
lengthy repetitive code that I copied
between experiment files you know okay
this check all these things but as a
famous data scientist once said when
you've written the same code three times
write a function when you've given the
same in person advice three times write
a blog post and I'll add to that when
you've run the same process three times
make a dashboard so I could have come up
with a solution here write of like
making another package that's what we
saw for the first problem was the
solution all this copy pasting but in
this case a dashboard is really what's
gonna be helpful and what it also did
was it it's building a tool that
empowers others we've heard a lot today
about how useful shiny can be if you saw
the presentation at 11 a.m. this morning
from Jacqueline and Heather nullus on
their work at t-mobile they talked about
how putting a shiny app and from the
stakeholders so they could play with a
machine learning model themselves is
what got them the resources to build out
a whole team so I built a shiny app for
showing our experiment data I started
with the health metrics so now for every
experiment these are automatically
calculated and we can know if
something's going
it's color-coded so we see that the
cookies duplicate cookies cookies a
multiple variation things look good it's
green cookies with no page use is not
looking as good its eye yellow and red
and so then that can suggest what we
might need to look into we have a
biometric view so if you want to look
for all the experiments that are running
or even all time how did all of those
affect chapter starts we can see all
right the control versus treatment the
percent change again this color coding
which is a small thing but it's nice
because at a glance I know what to take
from this alright three experiments
didn't have an impact the fourth one had
a negative impact and that will only
show in red when the p-value is less
than point zero five we also have our
nice confidence intervals again just for
some more visualization and helping to
understand these we have an individual
experiment view so now this shows the
description and the hypothesis because
as the experiment metrics crew as we
started tracking more we went from like
three to eleven became a bit cumbersome
to look just by metric and when you're
only interested in one experiment so
again all the information was there but
just making it easier for people to see
at a glance and to have this individual
experiment view and to level up a little
bit I would get a comm request of what
percent increased we detect in a
two-week test and this is a really
important question because otherwise you
may end up running tests you know say
you have a great idea I want to know are
we gonna increase registrations by
changing the color of a button but if
you run a power calculation this will
tell you alright in two weeks with the
amount of people who are visiting the
amount of people say register already
you would need a 50% increase in
registrations to detect a change so that
probably means you don't want to run
that test and I was really glad people
were asking this question I encouraged
them but could I make a tool set people
could answer this themselves without
code so I wanted to go from delivering
information to helping people discover
information and in the famous words of
Barney Simpson challenge accepted
we got the impact calculator so now
anyone at data camp can enter URLs here
and say they're interested in running
experiment on our homepage they can say
all right maybe I'm only interested in
signed out users maybe only mobile and
this table that you see will recalculate
and say all right first this is how many
unique users there are over a time
period this is what percent of them
start a chapter register etc so this is
really great because sometimes even just
from there she'll be like oh wow I
didn't realize these four URLs get so
little traffic probably doesn't make
sense for an experiment but the second
part is this has a power calculation
table underneath it so it will tell you
this answer that's the answer to this
question of an 18 days you'll be able to
detect an increase of say 4% for chapter
starts six and a half for registrations
and you know it's always a bit of a
guessing game of what impact your test
will have but usually someone you'll
have some sort of idea of what's
reasonable and so they could look at
this they could say all right well maybe
if I do both desktop and mobile is that
going to get me down to 3% if I make it
twenty five days instead and they could
iterate really quickly without ever
having to come to me and my final thing
that I learned was to make it easy to do
the right thing one best practice for EB
tests is to have a single key metric per
experiment
it helps clarify decision-making because
if you have multiple metrics and one
goes up and one goes down you could be
left not really knowing what you should
do in that situation it also allows you
to run that power analysis so for power
analysis to be run you need to have the
metric you need to know what's rate and
that can tell you how long to run the
experiment for so it's great at night
and I really I'm doing a lot to educate
people at data camp about a/b testing
best practices but you're more than that
but building it into the process and
making it easy for people so this is our
air table where we put the information
about our experiments and you could see
at the top here is a success metric and
so each experiment is required to have
one and only one we can write in the
notes maybe other things we care about
but this is the key metric and then we
can show you know then that forces
people make a decision we can match that
to something on the dashboard and it can
help make decision making at the end a
lot easier second guideline is to run
the
spearmint for the length you've planned
on this is a graph showing about how if
you ran it if you simulate thousands of
null experiments and you checked every
day if the p-value was less than point
zero five and you stopped your
experiment at that point you'd get an
over twenty percent false positive rate
so you know huge increase you really
want to you know do that power analysis
set the time of your experiment and
stick to it that's why we added to the
health checks metric a start date and an
end date for experiments again it could
be really tempting for a stakeholder to
you know message me hey I saw you know I
checked this dashboard on the individual
experiment this metric went up why don't
we just go ahead and launch it but now
they say okay I see the end date is not
for another couple days I know I'm
supposed to follow this best practice so
so I will do it so in conclusion to
recap build tools to save yourself time
that's where final join came out if
you're finding yourself doing something
over and over again it's really
worthwhile to invest some time and make
it easier and it also means the other
thing we found is that now a lot of
analyses we wouldn't have really started
before because they'd be a bit
cumbersome we have funnel join in our
back pocket and that can help us and we
know we can do it really quickly and it
enables us to do some more work
everything that can go wrong will go
wrong you have to check your assumptions
and build systems to do that build tools
that empower others especially I've
found effective dashboards and finally
make it easy to do the right thing it's
great to you know put in work educating
others may be in Searls to follow but
again the easier you can make it for
them to follow the best practice the
more likely you'll get the result you
want many thanks to the growth and data
science teams at data camp especially
David Robinson and Anthony Baker who are
co-authors of final join the analytics
and data engineering team at Etsy where
I was first a data analyst and with that
thank you very much and I'm happy to
take questions
[Applause]
you better get a question
thanks for putting this together any
words of caution before we rely on your
package on our own work yes so it's
funny when I gave this talk for the
first time back in October November
there was a big like caution sign that
was like still in beta the only thing I
would say is actually we like there's
some issues it hasn't been tested on non
Postgres remote tables I don't think it
would give you the wrong answer so much
is like not work some other behaviors we
know like there's it's it's there's a
bug sometimes you do multiple after
joins remotely but now we don't enable
you to do that we basically throw an
error so we've really tried where we can
to throw errors that being said we use
it very extensively at data camp it's
built with Travis GI you know there's a
bunch of tests we have but definitely
try it out but if something looks a
little wacky you know always
double-check of it but we found it
generally works pretty well
[Music]